a new tell all book spilling the Deets
on a feud between kamla Harris and Dr
Jill Biden
MD it claims the president's first
choice for his running mate was M
Michigan Governor Gretchen Whitmer Joe
thought cam was not up to the job of
commander-in-chief first lady was also
against Harris and favored Susan Rice
the good doctor couldn't stand the VP
due to her quote refusal to be a team
player but in the end it was Barack
Obama who foed comma on Joe Jesse it's
seems like it seems like the book
underscores what we already knew like
you she's unpopular and
incompetent that was your takeaway yes
great um I it looks like to me that
Obama has now chosen the two worst vice
presidents of all time Joe Biden and KLA
Harris but think about Greg how personal
a decision that is your vice
presidential choice I mean this is about
as person and impactful as you can get
and Biden just like had someone else
make the pick for him we're not talking
about two young guys like Bill Clinton
and Al Gore remember Biden came in and
said he was going to be a one- termer
and pass the torch I mean this is a huge
pick and he's like I'm just gonna let
Obama do it and so now it looks like by
tapping Kamala asvp that forces Joe to
run for reelection which guarantees a
trump Victory so when you think about it
when Obama tapped Hillary in 2016 it
gave us Trump and when he tapped Kamala
in 2020 it's going to give us Trump
again so thank you
Barack judge I mean she may have more
books written about her than Joe
Biden what she has earned every one of
those books I must tell you uh you know
the amazing thing is that you know why
would Barack Obama push her I mean when
you've got someone like Susan Rice or
you have someone like greter Whitner I
mean I don't agree with her politics but
she is is articulate she looks good uh
she's not laughing like there's
something wrong with her every time she
shows up somewhere I mean what is that
all about so um that's my opinion they
said quick at my ear so I'm done all
right you know Harold back in high
school I had a friend who taped a frozen
fish under the driver side seat of my
car until days later it started stinking
up the car is that what Obama did with
by by pushing kamla onto Joe Biden bad
analogy
it smells bad smells bad look there's
always some tension between these these
presidents and vice presidents you I
mean the Trump and Pence there were
there was Clinton and Gore there was
rumored to be by W and Cheney had a
little bit of it they said look this
this is what happens and winning solves
everything as the late great Al Davis
the former owner of the of the Raiders
set just win baby and if she's able to
help the team win in 24 all of this will
uh all this will you really believe
she's going to help the team win Harold
well she if they don't when they'll say
that she that that that she heard
it Dana you know another example of you
know you should have listened to your
spouse you know absolutely always listen
to Peter if if Whitmer had been the vice
president uh Joe Biden would not be
running for re-election the other thing
is there's some breaking news on the
campaign front the Biden Administration
wants to probably get rid of this book
and also get rid of the bad news cycle
that they've been in they are sending
jennnifer om Ali Dylan from the White
House back to the campaign so she'll be
heading up the campaign in Wilmington
that tells me they're taking the
criticism more seriously than ever wow
you heard it here first from Dana
breaking news
Perino all right one more thing's up
next hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else